got it cool hey wait just let me check  that that's pretty good I could just do  one more maybe hold on guys guys wait  wait one more real quick  honey it's my clock  no no no I told you give me no I have a  ton of technical are you serious you  monitors the earlier  oh wait didn't you a lot ocean out there  guys saying mom please work I don't know  why didn't have Chargers here got it  whoa okay that's good enough honey to go  put on some clothes it's just really  just they're people worried leering at  you just really quick honey we're  already burning we go through this every  time you just you look is it hard to get  to these places Oh  done oh my god I'm sorry man  Wow mean we're a better family than that  right guys a question yeah  Oh spamming selfie